lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
repasar lo que sabemos de gráficas de
línea y aplicarlas a una situación donde
algunos de nuestros datos involucren
fracciones nos dicen las longitudes de
algunas orugas se muestran a
continuación y podemos verlas justo aquí
en la gráfica de línea vamos a recordar
cómo se lee una gráfica de línea por acá
nos dicen que tenemos dos orugas que
tienen una longitud de cuatro
centímetros por acá tenemos tres orugas
con una longitud de siete centímetros
cada punto representa la longitud de una
oruga esta gráfica nos permite ver cómo
están distribuidas estas longitudes por
ejemplo tenemos un montón de orugas en
esta longitud cuál es esta longitud
bueno podemos ver que este valor se
encuentra en la mitad entre 4 y 5
entonces estas orugas miden 4
centímetros y medio
dividimos la distancia entre 4 y 5 en
dos secciones iguales y tomamos una de
esas dos secciones iguales para obtener
cuatro centímetros y medio así que
respondamos algunas preguntas primero
cuántas orugas en total se me dieron
pausa el vídeo y piénsalo bueno si cada
punto representa la longitud de una
oruga entonces tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 y 17
entonces medimos en total 17 orugas
siguiente pregunta cuántas orugas tienen
una longitud de 5 centímetros y un
cuarto pausa el vídeo y piense la
respuesta
bueno 5 centímetros y un cuarto es más
que 5 y que necesitamos hacer para
llegar a cinco y un cuarto bueno
necesitamos dividir el intervalo o la
longitud entre cinco y seis en cuatro
secciones iguales que ya nos las dan
observa 1 2 3 4 y necesitamos una de
estas secciones iguales entonces 5
centímetros y un cuarto está justo aquí
y podemos ver que sólo hay una oruga con
una longitud de 5 centímetros y un
cuarto ahora podemos preguntarnos
cuántas orugas tienen una longitud mayor
a 6 centímetros y un medio pausa el
vídeo e intenta responder
bien dónde estás 6 centímetros y medio
bueno podemos dividir la distancia entre
6 y 7 en dos secciones iguales y si
tomamos una de esas secciones iguales
llegaremos a seis y un medio así que
tenemos seis y un medio justo aquí
cuantas orugas tienen una longitud mayor
que seis centímetros y un medio bueno
podemos contarlas una dos tres cuatro
cinco y seis
la respuesta es seis incluso podemos
intentar responder preguntas como
cuántas orugas más tienen una longitud
de nueve centímetros y medio que cinco
centímetros y un cuarto intente
responder esa pregunta
bueno 9 centímetros y medio está la
mitad del camino entre 9 y 10 justo aquí
y podemos ver que sólo dos tienen una
longitud de 9 centímetros y medio y ya
sabemos que sólo una tiene una longitud
de 5 centímetros y un cuarto
así que cuantas más tienen una longitud
de 9 centímetros y medio que una
longitud de 5 centímetros y un cuarto
bueno esto es 2 menos uno que es
simplemente uno tenemos una oruga más
con una longitud de 9 centímetros y
medio que las que tenemos de 5
centímetros y un cuarto
bueno terminaré por aquí este vídeo pero
tenemos un montón de estos ejemplos en
khan academy para que practiques este
tema